While Fire & Blood states that Rhaenyra suffers
in childbirth for days, the show depicts her
labor as lasting one night.
Her daughter, who she names Visenya, is stillborn
in both the book and the series, but Fire
& Blood describes the child not only as deformed,
but part dragon.
It's up to the reader's interpretation if
this means Rhaenyra's child was literally
a dragon-human hybrid, or if it's a euphemism
for the result of generations of incest.
As we've seen in just one season of House
of the Dragon, Targaryen pregnancies don't
have a great track record.
The fact that Rhaenyra managed to birth five
healthy children is practically a miracle.
The House of the Dragon Season 1 finale doesn't
shrink away from her graphic sixth labor,
and lifeless Visenya is shown with a poorly
formed skull and missing limbs.
Perhaps as a nod to her dragon-like qualities
in the book, Visenya's birth is intercut with
flashes of Syrax roaring as her rider wails
in pain and grief.